[Music]
when the children look up at the night
sky
i want them to think about space
exploration
i want them to consider that they might
be the generation they have an
opportunity to go into space
[Music]
meet bjarke my name is jackie
gottfriedson i'm the founder and ceo of
excellent box
eggs in a box is a company that
developed all electronics component
mainly for the internet of things
industry all the way down to educational
industry basically he's a tinkerer and
he and his colleagues have cobbled
together this simple set of sensors that
will help these kids i'm angelique
get a lot closer to space that's
possible because well bjarka you tell
them we purchased the first privately
owned
satellite in africa and we did that with
the goal of having high school students
being able to build satellites
okay so here's how it works the students
get their hands on biarca's x in a box
sensors those ones which give real-time
readings on things like temperature
humidity and uv light levels then
they're built into biarca satellite
which is loaded onto a rocket like this
and then they're sent into lower earth
orbit we have stage one separation cool
right pretty cool these little things
are just going to be
in space recording everything we don't
know about what is it like up there
where we never been before and it's
really cool because we will get to see
that so just like that a bunch of kids
in south africa will be operating their
own classroom ground control playing
with data taken straight from outer
space
and that's all part of bjarka's plan
space is exciting it's interesting it's
that place we look in the night when we
look up in the stars and for a lot of
kids in
africa having an opportunity to be
included in the space industry is that
dream that might take them to just study
science technology and dna math in
general huh that's clever wonder if it's
working thinking of doing medicine plan
on studying for about
7 to 12 years to become a neurologist
one day i would actually
want to work with these things because
they are just so interesting
technology and math and science and
engineering has made all of what we are
now possible and that's why it's
important
[Music]
you